oh looks great where are you
i'm in muskoka oh congrats that looks
beautiful i hope you're having a fun
time yeah
you need to come here oh it's a pretty
great place looks great
you're a little busy right now with an
amazing movie congratulations
it has received so much buzz early buzz
already what does that feel like
exciting it's really exciting the movie
um i think it was it was scheduled to
come out about a year ago
um and it's been sort of pushed and
pushed and stuff
but yeah very exciting i mean
we finished working on it so long ago it
um
you know
yeah it feels like a while and i'm happy
that it's coming out
what does it feel like to go up against
ryan reynolds to get the girl that's
what i want to know like i mean you're
the guy
you know i think um
right well i without giving too much
away i i really love how
ryan uh jody and my arc are all sort of
intertwined in this really delicate way
and it sort of unfolds uh as you're
watching the movie as well so
i guess i'll kind of leave it at that
but
yeah i love ryan he's the man
going up against ryan reynolds in the
love category i mean come on that is
that is something though that's next
level
what was it like on set i mean ryan ryan
creates a a pretty pretty incredible set
uh wherever he goes what was that
experience like for you he does he
really does um
and i knew sean i knew sean's you know
sort of atmosphere that he does on set
and actually him and him and ryan work
in a very similar way where they just
just want to make everyone feel really
comfortable
and want to have a light and happy mood
on set which goes a long way i mean
you'd be surprised that like if you're
not comfortable or if people are
you know second guessing things it can
really actually sort of take away from
the final product and i think that
fostering this creative and
collaborative environment is is really
key and and they know that it's
something i learned working with them
what is your key to keeping a straight
face when someone like ryan is
cracking it out of nowhere and
ad-libbing and doing the things do you
pinch your leg like what do you do to
keep it straight
you know just don't want to mess up the
take really the focus is you know if
they're doing something that's really
amazing you just don't want to be the
one to mess up the take so i've
definitely had my moments of breaking
and stuff because how can you not but
yeah
i should probably adopt something though
maybe i should be pinching my leg that's
probably a good idea
you can take that that's one for me
um
you're calling in from the the set of
stranger things is that right i actually
um uh i'm not calling no i'm uh do we're
doing a big old uh you know junket for
the for the show i uh
yeah stranger things no i i just mean
you're in the middle of shooting right
now is anybody trying to get secrets out
of you about this movie because it's a
pretty anticipated movie oh uh
some of the cast mates were asking me
about it yeah they were trying to i'm
pretty i mean coming from uh stranger
things i'm pretty tight-lipped about
everything just because
you know i never want to be the one to
spoil anything so i've been trained
pretty well
amazing well congratulations on this
movie it was just what we all need this
summer so thank you so much that's
that's great thank thanks so much and
yeah enjoy your vacation looks beautiful
thank you so much you got to get up here
i will
okay
be well you too